you are watching ColdFusion TV a note to
the viewer I don't usually say this but
it's imperative that you pay attention
to the entirety of this production what
you're about to see may very well be the
future of computing and may affect you
directly in the future that being said
please enjoy the production since the
dawn of our modern civilization humans
have been pushing towards something
we've continuously been creating tools
to make our lives easier tools to help
us build survive and thrive within the
circumstances of the age tools such as
language mathematics and science helped
build early society and of course
sometimes greed and the love of power
did get in the way of this concept but
the creation of new tools never stopped
directly after the great war of the 20th
century we saw unparalleled prosperity
and more positive changes to society
than ever before and a few decades later
came the tool that truly changed the
world
the microchip as the Industrial
Revolution expanded human ability in a
physical sense by amplifying human
strength
the microchip revolutionised and
amplified the power of the human brain
we then saw the pace of Technology
increase at a brand-new level even
during the decades of conflict a new age
of rapidly evolving applications for the
microchip came to fruition after this
the internet Shrunk the world and
consolidated all of humanity's
information in one place all of our
history thoughts and ideas were put
together and coupled with a dynamic
experience featuring real-time
interactions between individuals
communities and even political figures
currently we live in a time like no
other and we all know it but what tool
is next after the Internet what is the
next game changing type of technology
as we fast approached the middle of the
2010s it's clear that we've had plenty
of new emerging technologies such
advances have seen 3d printed houses
food and most recently and probably most
surprising 3d printed human body organs
in addition to this we've seen a new
type of legitimate decentralized
currency without a Federal Reserve to
Tainter cryptocurrency we've also seen
the rise of the ultralight drone is
applications banned from surveillance to
civilian uses with the aid of the
smartphone drones can perform incredible
feats unimaginable to the common
consumer just a decade ago and to top it
off we have the rather dexterous robots
recently brought under Google's wing but
what if I told you that all this paled
in comparison to the implications of the
next wave of Technology and why is that
you might ask well this next technology
was designed to operate like the human
brain let me bring this to you in the
form of a question what if there was an
artificial intelligence machine so
powerful that it could take any
information and quickly learn everything
there is to know about that information
and then give you relevant answers to
naturally ask questions
backed by reasoning in other words
extremely advanced machine learning that
results in reasoning what if this
machine could aid in finance scientific
research health care provide business
solutions revolutionize the food
industry and much more so what am I
talking about exactly here welcome to
the world of IBM Watson so what is it
Watson at its core is a supercomputer
but the genius is really in the software
it was hand-built by IBM and has cloud
computing in mind in a nutshell it's the
cutting edge of artificial intelligence
many levels above anything we've seen
before so you might be thinking how is
this any different to Google or Google
now or please pay close attention here
because this is where your discovery
begins the best way to highlight the
massive implications of this artificial
intelligence is to show you a demo I
want you to take particular note of the
steps that the system is taking so one
of the prototype systems that we're
building is something we call
bader we give it freewheeling
understanding of large bodies of
information like Wikipedia and we asked
the computer with no human intervention
construct arguments pro and con on any
subject we throw at it and the result of
that is what I'd like to show in the
demonstration now so as I said we could
throw any subject at it I've chosen some
here let's just pick the first one so it
will now look for all in all the
literature and try to understand as a
computer what's a pro and what's a con
for violent video game games let's roll
the first one scanned approximately 4
million Wikipedia articles returning 10
most relevant articles scanned all 3,000
sentences and top 10 articles detected
sentences which contain candidate claims
identified borders of Canada claims
assessed pro and con polarity of can of
it claims construct a demo speech with
top claim predictions ready to deliver
you have selected the topic the sale of
violent video games to minors should be
banned I would like to raise the
following points in support of the topic
exposure to violent video games results
in increased physiological arousal
aggression related thoughts and feelings
as well as decreased per social behavior
in addition these violent games are
lyrics actually caused adolescents to
commit acts of real-life aggression
finally violent video games can increase
children's aggression on the other hand
I would like to note the following
claims that oppose the topic violence in
video games is not causally linked with
aggressive tendencies in addition most
children who play violent games do not
have problems
finally video game play is part of an
adolescent boys normal social setting
would you like to discuss another topic
and so as as you can see if we can go to
the final chart again completely unaided
by humans the system went through all of
this knowledge and constructed and
reasoned will then quote on its own now
think about what this means it's no
longer a game man versus machine it's
man and machine reasoning together I
believe this is the future of computing
thank you thank you
so that demonstration was pretty cool
but it's just the beginning the thing
that's most incredible about IBM Watson
is what it can do without the internet
like what you may ask how about beating
two Jeopardy game show champions Watson
had no help no internet the computer was
asked questions in the same way as the
guests and at the same time as the
guests still you are right
what is violin but who is the church
lady yes Watson
what is narcolepsy you are right and
with that you move to thirty six
thousand six hundred baby
who is Bram Stoker and the laser
Oh 17,000
and a two-day total
of 77,000
I would have thought the technology like
this was years away but it's here now I
have the bruised ego to prove it my past
jeopardy experiences have been great but
they weren't really weighty with this
kind of technological philosophical
importance I think we saw something
important today and that was three years
ago
the system is much better today so much
so that in February 2013 IBM announced
that Watson's first software system
application will be for management
decisions in lung cancer treatment at
Kettering Cancer Center it has shown
that treatment one has a 95 percent
confidence of being effective whereas
treatment two is only half that is so
obscure that you would have needed
Watson for the diagnosis and treatment
or an oncologist come up with the same
treatment in fact this is such a new
discovery of this particular mutation
and it's a relatively new drug as well
that my guess is that many oncologists
may not be quite up to speed yet Watson
has been so accurate that today 90% of
nurses in the field he is Watson now
follow its guidance for a first
application of a new type of technology
of this nature this success is almost
unheard of all of this recent progress
was somewhat unexpected but Watson as a
tool will only grow in application and
power as time passes let's take a look
at one more application of Watson before
we break it down and see what this all
means and how this technology might be
relevant to you in the future from
traders at Citigroup the bank hired
Watson for his first foray into
financial services so what does the big
bank expect to get from the trivia Wiz
the Toronto Star says the bank will use
Watson to taken everything from
information about customers profiles and
banking activities to corporate
quarterly reports analyst reports
regulations credit ratings government
securities filings and the institution's
own rules
it could also gather intelligence from
online news reports blogs and Twitter
feeds there's a lot to take in but the
bottom line is that Watson is showing
some very real promise of giving
accurate answers to anything if you give
it information or study material if you
will
all of this being said there is a touch
of concern among some Watson displays
ability to give reasonable answers in
the fields of expertise that would
otherwise require years of industry
experience although today Watson is
still a tool and a guide the obvious
question is could Watson replace
expensive employees that are currently
within the same area of operation even
though many said the same thing would
happen with the microchip in the 1970s
nobody can know this for sure if the job
depends mostly on research and reasoning
it could very well be a possibility the
technology behind Watson is very
exciting due to the fact that in
November 2013 IBM announced that will
make Watson available to software
developer providers this enables them to
build apps and services that are
embedded with Watson's capabilities in
short Watson may be coming to a mobile
device near you using the cloud of
course and in fact it's already on iPad
for the medical professionals mentioned
earlier in the video in a previous
episode of ColdFusion TV we've seen just
how large Google became by providing the
service of easy to find information
imagine providing the service of
accurate answers to all information the
implications of such a powerful tool are
both exciting and confronting at the
same time but what can we take away from
all this looking at the wider picture
although Watson is smarter than a human
it's not necessarily more intelligent
after all humans built Watson in the
first place so that's all the latest
information on the greatest artificial
intelligence to exist on this planet
today Watson may just be the most
advanced tool we've created yet let's
see what changes it causes within
society in the future
hey guys here the creator of that video
and of course this channel I just want
to thank you guys watching the whole way
through and it's just really insane when
you sit down and think about all this
technology that's happening in our world
today and just have little people
actually really know about it so yes
it's going to be a really interesting
time when all this comes into fruition
actually matures in a technological
sense but anyway I just wanted to thank
you guys for watching and if you did
enjoy that please give it a thumbs up
and maybe subscribe if you liked it and
share it to a friend if you think they
would be interested in this kind of
technology which I think most people
should actually take a look at what's
actually happening today but um yeah I
think that's enough for me so until next
time have a good one enjoy yourselves
and I catch you again soon for the next
video
Cheers cold chicken are you thinking